we didn't see you there
hi my name is Greg I'm John John and
Craig today are gonna watch and review
hopefully be able to because there's no
subtitles for Sadako Sadako uh yeah oh
god I couldn't don't if you don't know
don't try Kyle I think it's yeah Sadako
versus camp oh yeah your guess is as
good as mine the ring wishes the garage
yes we're moving rate versus the grudge
we go yeah so there's no subtitles for
this so I decided to read the plot
beforehand John can you read the plot
out loud sure a girl URI kurahashi after
watching a cursed videotape together
with her friend in a haunted house
becomes trapped in a conflict between
the two murderous ghosts Sadako Yamamura
and kaya koseki the ring in the ground
ring in the grudge so this person
watched the video incest out of the girl
wishes like goofy [ __ ] you so awesome
yeah that's the purpose that's the only
way it'll make sense yeah you gotta do
it that way it's an appropriate level
wackiness I hope this trailer includes
ah
like a YouTube video I don't know what
it says
it's almost creepier that way
it's nice that this in do you know
haunting the law couple do you like it
always add that sounds were thinkin the
well is outside of the Raj house when
you're bucking Mohinder I remember when
that first happened I was so scary oh
the [ __ ] is going off I
wonder what their hours are gonna get
worried - no no
southern bosses call you and she's
caught in the middle they're fighting
about who gets to haunt this person oh
my that's a crazy trailer I don't know
if it's like it the weight Japanese
trailers go where it just totally
shifted into like this rocking out kind
of heavy metal music well I almost think
this trailer is designed to make us go
like okay all that creepy like dread
[ __ ] you love from the first the
original movies that's here and then the
trailer kicks into like because this is
such a wacky premise we're gonna kind of
be self-conscious about it I don't know
I mean I I feel like they're committing
to it because the setup is scary but
think about it like the phones probably
gonna be kind of goofy in its own way
the thing about sydejko versus kayak Oh
in the movies you don't really see them
do you know like whatever is they do to
the human beings usually cuts away right
before they do something to them that
like this figures them yeah them look
[ __ ] weird do that freaked me out the
first time so hard when you made me
watch the ring in the dark yeah I
remember that when they first find her
in the closet she's all like green and
twisted up my hands now that was one of
the most hilarious experiences of my
entire life you I remember you I
remember how you reacted to it - you
were like cuz when I showed cousin or
Verbinski just does like quick cut to it
yeah I have no choice mr. watch it lands
you of the first girl was dead and like
in the closet or something he just went
I was like dude what's wrong accepted
death and accepted impend I knew it -
it's wrong like oh just I gotta make
peace it's like open up man what's wrong
I want to check it out just to see like
if they actually see what they do like
the craziness of like what what attacks
are they gonna do on each other it's a
little bit trying to put together here
see I feel like this is gonna start out
like at least where the trailer gives me
is like this would start out like a J
horror movie with all that creepy like
ghost stuff they do partway through it's
bringing two monsters together is so
Godzilla then I gotta imagine they'll
make it kind of like Godzilla vs Mothra
or something just have it be a little
more badass it looks like they're having
fun with it but also not like it doesn't
look like they're goofing on it like
they're still being true to it maybe
what what do you think I'm asleep oh
yeah I was noticing I before there you
go
thanks man we read each other well
should we should we take that room again
no it's humble to let people see you at
your most vulnerable point should your
like you for forcing this development on
me um looking at the camera but okay
this girl who's like trapped in the
middle oh that's unfortunate
I know I want this movie to be fun you
know like I feel like the trailer is
confusing on what tone it's going for I
would like it to be a fun movie as well
I feel like it could kind of be Evil
Dead style like Sam Raimi style you know
well that's sort of hoping and I think
if they did that I think it could be a
really cool film actually if this
trailer is honest I get the sense that
they are kind of gonna kind of try and
do that be like we're gonna have fun
with this but we're also gonna give you
the kinds of scares you love from the
movies that's what the first half
communicates to me is like we haven't
lost all of the J or ghosts you know
twisted 'no still have no idea why
they're fighting though yeah I don't
need it I think I think that's literally
someone said won't happen if you watch
the ring tape in the grudge house so I
was like well something would happen you
know like like if both of those ghost
stories exist then they would be caught
into the same space so you can like
theorize then I mean why would they
start versing each other why can't they
just go because the ring chick probably
wants to take over the house perfu she
wants to move out of the well get some
digs in town the chances of this
happening are so slim I gotta capitalize
or she just wants to move in with them
and they go if you beat us in battle you
can have any room beautiful
and then this is all opening up their
sitcom Cinematic Universe were like all
the ghosts live together like the ghost
from shudder and the ghosts from eyes or
whatever but the eye or whatever they
all live in like a you know one place
they're like the agents of shield thank
you
this is really validating I would like
to take this moment to thank everybody
supported me okay I remember watching
the ring growing up and that there were
some fun times there I would like to
share some of those fun memories with
you one time I showed my dad the ring he
fell asleep in the living room floor II
fell asleep he woke up 20 minutes before
us mara mara Samara came out of the
television and when that moment came on
the TV my dad oh no started losing his
[ __ ] he started rolling around freaking
out no no no that's if it was really
happening to it my first real girlfriend
Haley Dennett Oh how's your marriage no
my first date with her we went to go see
The Grudge horrible idea I think it's
the reason we broke up Megan yeah maybe
yeah that [ __ ] came between us those
movies and ready man and that little boy
wouldn't leave no cat meowing I feel
like a little actually a little boy is
pulling off someone's head yeah he was
yeah his greed has a creepiest part
something that looks like it's gonna
bring the craziness it seems like
they're really taking the effort to go
crazy because like even that kind of
effect like watching it looked like a
practical watching someone's head like
stretch out it's kind of surreal he's
looking characters are haunting you know
like in their solo like I remember
watching even the ring I never saw the
original ring you I did watch you on and
Joe on - yeah but I wish I saw the
original ring me sure what if it could
be no it's - security see anything is
like I didn't watch a lot of j-horror
growing up I do find myself missing it
now so I'm happy to see is like I want
to return because I feel like their
movies are genuine
creepy and haunting yeah there's a get
under your skin and make you feel
uncomfortable you know there's a tone
and like an approach to the rules of the
spirits and how they treat these things
it's very human in a no way and it's and
then they do these uncanny things that
twist that you inform like in ways to
disconcert you and it's like they have a
singular kind of a tone like in they do
it like it always scares me it's like
low-budget effects most of the time too
you know it makes it that much creepier
when they pull it off you know I feel
like what Studios like big studios fun
like a horror film I feel like they get
carried away when they really like these
films come down to great editing awesome
camerawork awesome cinemates when it
comes down to filmmaking for these
movies the work you know well yeah and I
always feel like J horror movies are
more spectral and more sort of um they
they're more like Jesus dude no it's
like the secret no no it's an adjective
use our books no but they have this tone
that's like very foreboding and dready
and like even if somebody you know
manages to escape this situation a lot
will have been lost it'll still be kind
of ugly and and and scary you know which
side do you want to win probably it
wasn't kind of cool like killed by her
husband or something and yeah I want a
kayak go to one because I hope to have
children like that one day well no cuz
then like Sonico uh there's a whole like
they have so much backstory for these
characters now it's like the woman with
the hairbrush is like her mom and she
was like super abusive and stuff like
that and like threw her down the well
like all these yeah like tear I don't
know I feel like there's maybe slightly
more innocence in Kyoto but I don't know
very well who do you choose
so on principle I would choose Kyoto
from The Grudge but I kind of feel like
Sadiq Oh would win cuz suckish is like
she's so kind of at least see again at
least from the ring you know we gotta go
back and watch ring you remember I just
feel like she's so angry she's going to
win it's just there's it's so bleak the
Bleeker ghost will win I feel like these
teachers found Jesus everything we go
okay we just need our own they just need
to find each other what's up friends and
family um family Oh what my family
doesn't watch this channel what if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe today and I would like it
come rechecked as we like to say here
and John has a playlist called reasons
to charity it's the videos he's featured
in this podcasts that he's so consistent
on Verde guests tubs and you can follow
us on Facebook we're really on top of
the Facebook lately the Instagram hell
yeah I'm been posting I went down a
slide recently and I showed that [ __ ] on
my insta Twitter I use it once and wow
that's all the goal to get more product
placement people we're gonna remove at
the product placement joke oh yeah for
things such as the power oh man the
power is a great book it's about love
and the power of love love is
essentially the power and how you can
attract almost anything not almost you
try anything you want into your life
with the power of love I might have
heard of the law of attraction it's
really the law of love and also product
placement for a good pillow because like
a good pillow is indispensable like so
many great uses are you making a joke of
my positivity no I'm trying to
acknowledge the positivity of this
pillow and if they would product with
you if you have chronic place up
certainly nominate
you feel good that's what's happening
that's when I have my pillow I want you
to have its your pillow it's not over I
am not having